it exists it's pretty and you race cars
in it sorry but it's difficult to work
up excitement over driveclub it's a
bare-bones racing game in which thrills
are in short supply
this is racing in its driest form free
of frills ends free of pressing reasons
to invest in it for the long term no in
spite of its attempts to drive
competition by way of automated and
player issue challenges
driveclub is a short-term game there's
no fuss no under the hood tinkering just
basic time trials races and a few drift
events driveclub
introduces you to a variety of appealing
vehicles and puts them to the test on a
variety of intricate tracks and in that
sense driveclub succeeds a Bentley
Continental might be a lot heavier than
the various Audi's and Aston Martin's
but they all feel great to drive your
initial races won't demand so much of
you but if there's one thing drive club
has a handle on its how to smartly
increase the level of challenge moving
from hot hatches to sport vehicles and
beyond all well opening access to curvy
tracks that won't forgive your silly
cornering mistakes when your primary
conflict is with the track and its
complexities driveclub induces the right
kind of tension it's all about the
anxiety of the corner approach followed
by the relief of uninterrupted
acceleration
ái racers can and do offer a challenge
but sometimes because they behave in
irritating ways causing the game to
punish you for its own mistakes your AI
opponents are concerned above all else
with the racing line regardless of which
car they drive their lack of
adaptability later in the single-player
tour is a problem
AI racers tend to clump up around
certain curves and ignore the presence
of other vehicles including your own AI
vehicles prefer collisions to deviations
from the line often smashing at you from
behind and sending you for reading and
the vehicle in front of you or sliding
onto the shoulder a collision or an
overturned corner is damaging on its own
in any racing game but in driveclub it's
even more so should you veer too far
from the pavement or should the game
determine that a collision is too
violent the game slows you down for
several crucial seconds in drive Club
there's nothing more frustrating than a
collision that is clearly not your fault
and the slowdown that follows online
play removes the AI frustrations but
there's a little more to say about it
except that it functions and it
functions well
this is the driveclub experience by and
large though there are embellishments
worth noting there are the club's
themselves for example which allow a
half-dozen friends to come together
design a badge create a personalized
paint job and invite other clubs to beat
their race times there are the many
challenges to bite-sized trials that
spur you to drift a corner for longer
than a club mate or to more accurately
follow the official race line for a
period of time
these are nice basic features but
driveclub fails to present them with any
energy or excitement the dull menu music
signals a dull overall presentation the
cars and environments are an arguably
gorgeous but the game is largely
lifeless it's hard to find any true
celebration of car culture here drive
Club is ordinary menus and ordinary
races drive Club is bland sound effects
and bland social competition drive Club
is the fear of risks and the embrace of
the ordinary it's basic racing in basic
packaging beautiful and inert and full
of great cars that feel good to drive it
is not however an argument for a new
generation of driving given how it fails
to exceed the standards of the old one